Lisa Lampanelli hi Lisa how are you good
to see you so unexpected and disliked I
forget Loveridge he's like one of the
few people I go he actually apologized
to me once because he hurt my feelings
you know oh he's such it was such a dick
back in the day I still it still is yes
well I think inside he's a sweet deep
human being you know with all that
stupid addiction crap that he's always
spouting about listen to me to Tony on
purpose is there nowhere like yours yes
take the cap off stupid appropriate 160
year old woman either who's not a dyke
yet wait no he was so nice too because
one time he made a joke about me not on
stage and cuz I'm staged it doesn't
bother you then while she was like boy
that was mean he comes by and he goes to
me Li Shan you know what yeah you know
I'm kidding right you know I'm kidding
right and I he says it 50 times like it
and still does it like continuously
throughout the rest of your life it
counts yeah I think making amends to me
for the last 25 years no I always have a
good big heart for you and I always
wonder how Bonnie freaking tamed you
because you're nicer now don't remember
how I stuck up for you and Amster you
did Brian I came to introduce that I'm
here yet let me tell you what happened
ironically last week a guy interviewed
me about Patrice O'Neal yeah and I said
I forgive him because he called me and
asked forgiveness also which I thought
was a big deal because the truce didn't
give a [ __ ] about anybody know so this
rich Ross and me and Patrice go to do
these shows in Amsterdam the stupid
comedy festival that was not even in
Amsterdam it was like some Rotterdam
yeah it's [ __ ] horrible stupid
so we're there and I had strep throat so
I was needed sleep and every time that
[ __ ] fat bastard Patrice walked by me
on the plane he would like punch me and
wake me up and I'm like like I'm a fat
[ __ ] at the time but I'm like I am still
a girl like Anna
six we'll stop punching me and they
couldn't take it anymore and each other
bawling in the bathroom because at heart
I'm a big [ __ ]
and boss came talked me off the ledge
and I think it's because you have
daughters too because you get it it's
because he had a [ __ ] you in the
bathroom you got we I'll tell you what
happened this is at the club it's a
different way we're gonna go to the
red-light district and you said I want
to hang out and Patricia off you can't
come with us and you were in the
bathroom yeah it all came to a [ __ ]
well well it all started with the
airport and when yeah and I went in the
bathroom to control you but see when the
ladies into Hudson wanna see other girls
come in well that is true and I know it
but what's great about it is you showed
aside to you that was so nice that you
could have gotten laid there by those
chicks are overheard how nice you were
but I guess you were I actually think
you're really sexy that's right effed up
about me grab that shirt from very
terrible the Jewish
[Applause]
he's flexing now if he's doing this for
Lisa see I have no muscle tone B even
though I lost the weight I don't work
out and on that [ __ ] I don't believe in
it do you don't put it up if it's bad
listen I tried he really is body
dysmorphia sit down can you turn that
screen on Troy so that we can look at
and then you show us the photo and we'll
find out it's bad it's good you don't go
after the 6-pack then he's clearly in
great shape but you don't care about
definition I don't I'm sick I want to do
stand-up with my shirt off 61 huh yeah
now I hit 57 last year and had a
profound change I decided that a nice
person inside and I don't mind people
knowing it that's why I'm being so nice
to you today why were you always I you
weren't you don't people to see how nice
your shirk I'm a [ __ ] the only person
who saw me cry in all those many years
of comedy was this guy damn rich Ross
and a bathroom in Amsterdam just so he
could get some [ __ ] right listen but
here's the difference people that's the
problem P I think that you know you're a
massive can't know what was wrong with
that you big who you are on stage in in
real life yes and you're not that person
right and that's why Whitney Cummings
and I had talked about when after we did
that roast at Trump were like should we
ever do a roast again because people
think we can actually take a joke and we
can't so we were like we're not doing
roasted because it teaches people how to
treat you on the street for the next 20
years of your life so you have everybody
coming up to say hey you fat [ __ ] and at
the time it hurt my feelings because I
was a fact I'm now they could say
anything they want cuz I'm freaking
clearly hot as [ __ ] yeah you do look
good I do
aye-aye-aye oh my god your picture is up
speaking right yeah who's watching this
picture
don't be deluded by this false
definition he has he's scratching over
[Laughter]
it's okay if you ever take your shirt
off
very aggressive room tell me I can't
punch down after you all that you're too
short we watch footage of you in some
room and we're towards Detroit you are
[ __ ] hey I'll tell you exactly what
is it yeah with the headline the Lisa
Lampanelli meltdown I [ __ ] loved by
the way because it's more attention
hello
but wonder what really happened is so
freaking great okay I had six months of
shows back to back like every single
weekend I can't stand it I need to work
I shouldn't have to work I have money
I'm not rich Voss desperate for the
attention stage time in my color however
I crossed a ball as they say so I am at
the final two gigs the second to last
one in San Jose California I'm up there
and it's when all this me to [ __ ] is
going on now I never got me to what I
happened was I have a sensitivity
towards people telling me to shut up
because my father was a gentleman and he
died recently he never told me to shut
up my brother a gentleman never told no
man has ever told me to shut up
so this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm trying to be
nice Jim because that's why I asked if
you changed in your life a little bit as
with a urine I'm trying to be nicer
offstage there's this [ __ ] [ __ ] in the
awning on stage off stage
I'm sorry there's this nice lady she
couldn't see cuz some tall [ __ ]
idiots in front of her and she had a
cast on her leg so I go to her honey you
look miserable move up a little there
was a couple seats I go move up come on
so she's taken too long and this [ __ ]
[ __ ] yells shut up the - he is well I
don't know it's that's a hot button
telling me to show I was triggered to
like oh really I will [ __ ] kill you
and I said deliberately don't make it
funny
make it angry and I had no choice I
[ __ ] snap it's like a postal worker
yeah so I go up to him this is the best
part I go up to him I go dude I go you
don't like it you shut the [ __ ] up
hey I said you know what I learned this
from Joey Vega this other comic years
ago I love Joey I love this great guy
I'm sure you talked to everybody on the
photo every time you [ __ ] say that
all right
I said say the guy I will pay you to
leave I go you know what I said give me
tell me how much you paid for a ticket
I'll [ __ ] give it to you so I always
keep like 50 bucks in my pocket right in
Rich's case it would be like eight I go
to the guy all right I'll pay you to
leave and he says he's so [ __ ] dumb
he goes I'll pay you to shut up and I go
okay like you're gonna give me money
I'll [ __ ] take it the guy gives me a
20 well I say what are the optics on
this you know somebody's taping it
probably sure so I go I could either
crumble it up and throw it at him I
could rip it up which looks wasteful or
I could just I don't know I should have
thought about giving it to a charity
that's what I should have said I should
say this is going to the me toos that
you tried to cornhole against their will
you know however I just crumpled threw
it in his face
and then I threw the [ __ ] mic and I
said I did my hour suck my [ __ ] all he
is and I [ __ ] left and this is my
feeling once I fulfill my obligation
suck my dick cured he was you know not
exactly right and yet no more than that
whatever because I was like closing it
up anyway oh you are okay here's what
bothers me did you do the times yet the
what nothing go ahead it doesn't make
any sense
say that from an ancient reference from
when he was born his mom was a cocktail
waitress on Noah's Ark okay so listen I
feel I stood behind that that's why I
called TMZ cuz from the plane I saw the
quote I go we can't wait to get on the
ground and FaceTime about this because I
was right like I think you're right you
don't have to take abuse off somebody so
yeah that snap was worth lovin I said
every comic has [ __ ] snap yeah
someone you just even hate their face oh
god yeah they're just sitting here yeah
it's a mirror every comic look he wasn't
right and I don't even want to bring up
his name but you don't know what you
never know what goes on what the hell is
happening with somebody but also for it
before they lose your career right
doesn't matter Michael Richards oh yeah
that guy I forgot the famous mystery
really but here's what here's what
really happened okay he said I don't
want to mention his name but it's
because he didn't remember right and I
also felt it was freaking great
publicity like shut up I know you
actually have some power on the show
which you guys in your heart you had a
nice this to you and everybody has a
nice that they're born with but somebody
kind of beats it out of you or somebody
craps on you and you turn into a [ __ ]
monster like yourself yes rich just do
me a favor since I feel like it's very
I'm very happy to see you because
usually I'm like get the [ __ ] another
kamikaze I was so happy to see plug your
date for the New York Comedy Festival
I'm not I know
no Gramercy Theater will not let you in
on misty that's why I'll text you after
and go I hope I didn't hurt your
feelings absolutely not you are superior
and I will tell you the one thing Jim
that makes me mad about rich roses every
[ __ ] time I go to Canada when I go
through a customs line and they say do
you have anything to declare and I want
to say war on Canada because that's like
his best joke which is so great
but it's five albums no but I know no
query nominations so I'm doing and it's
terrific
who's that like it's ro
do not tell me Maguire is still doing
comedy great now no I haven't done that
room in 20 years Jim was John Ryerson
clubs let me tell you if I do can I tell
you one really funny story about Maguire
that [ __ ] John Ryerson that crazy
Mick here's what happened remember big
Frank D'Amico I'm sure okay
might show what the grand mature is a
lot about weight issues I met Frank
right yeah for a while
he big guy he was like 400 pounds I have
a lot of stories about his very great
guy but he said he's dead now which is
great for comedy
well this Ryerson was such a [ __ ]
drunk when he owned the place I don't
know if he is anymore then you do three
shows on a Saturday but every time you
introduce Frank and talk about Frank it
get more insulting like the first show
the seven o'clock show we'd go like Oh
your headliner tonight big Frank D'Amico
clap-clap-clap second show tonight
big fat 11 o'clock it was big fat tits
that hang things constantly Frank are
like drunken [ __ ] what are you gonna say
about me with the Dyke hair you know I'm
saying
John Rother I have a diamond I always
liked him he was always nice to me
everybody what a drunk he got mad at me
because I was heckled once and I went
off on the guy in the guy left without
paying and I go I wasn't a Joey Vega at
the time I didn't have that ball or
money to throw around and say oh I'll
pay his tab for him but he yells at me
for handle a heckler he's [ __ ] crazy
do you worry that win a video like like
the TMZ video comes out of these stories
coming out that people are gonna go and
want to heckle you because it's like now
it's a thing maybe I hope they don't I
hope they know that I always win like
because we always win when is it last
time you saw a comic really lose lose of
any caliber yeah it's very very hard to
lose with the mic and with the timing
it's really it's hard when you do for a
living
yeah we're not use best thing at
Caroline's was once when years ago when
I was still doing clubs like rich still
is that they have a bachelorette party
as you know which is always the worst so
I'm screaming at these [ __ ] I say you
got one last chance I go one more
[ __ ] sound just one and they [ __ ]
they give you ten minutes like oh we're
gonna let her get her guard down they
[ __ ] make a sound I go out get the
[ __ ] out and they walk out and they say
to Kenny who used to manage the place
they go Oh Kenny they go we're not
[ __ ] and he goes ma'am because I've
been in this business 20 years you are
among the top five [ __ ] now that's a
[ __ ] Club the back [ __ ] that's right
Caroline's with boot people there's
nothing worse than when you call for
security get them out and this no one
shows y'all cricket cricket oh oh my god
our list and they're like a eunuch okay
I was [ __ ] drunk [ __ ] with me he
goes why why did you go back after the
drunk I go why do you keep serving them
yep you thank you that scene for a movie
what's that I'm telling it's compelling
you know what I know you're the best
place to do comedy is Salt Lake City
Utah I love that kid cuz you go there
they do not allow drinks in the theater
there's like a curfew on drinking so you
can only drink in certain bars at
certain times but [ __ ] place is
silent like when you do jokes
it's so fantastic I know did that ever
make it out in the theaters you kidding
me how well that movie I was ashamed to
see it because I was fat at the time and
I said oh I don't
shot you from the head because I was
misshapen and how I was pretty heartfelt
I must say was a movie called again darn
funny is that they are now I like the
person bought for me once the website
gash ain't funny calm which I thought
was you antastic I own it now they
bought it for you ain't funny
hey effect because you know you you do
racial stuff like are you [ __ ]
panicking about what's going on now or
do you still do the same stuff or do you
kind of direct it a little different now
I like I said I've taken a little time
off from stand-up and I'm doing like
this storytelling show now no with other
actors and well check this out this
racial stuff however I never seem to get
a backlash because like they know what
they're getting when they come to see
what you do it doesn't seem Millennials
have no idea who I am they listen to
these things called these podcasts right
this thing called the internet not me
not me if you're over 30 you may know
who I am so you know that is a strong oh
so even if my fans are over 60 I don't
care cuz you're rich
having had no fans yourself you
understand what no rich have you played
video stress factory up in Connecticut
yet
like it I I liked it but it was it was a
put on sale on short notice that's what
everyone says and they don't sell a lot
of tickets and I understand its and the
upper balcony was uh that's okay cuz can
I take a look ten minutes from that
place
I still haven't walked in but my sister
she goes all the time she says it's
terrific and the reason I ask is why are
you playing clubs Jim Norton
you seem very above it rich I have no
question no and when I work clubs
sometimes de courten off to second row
the old days before its resurgence Jim
Breuer would sometimes play that
Westbury music fair and half half of the
clothes now it's open to shows whatever
but I can the curtain is the saddest
club sometimes I mean theaters are fine
but I mean I still like doing clubs and
if the money's got money good money is
all that counts the money always like to
think I'm gonna give the money to
charity and I never do nope that's right
definitely not money I wanted I just you
were on Celebrity Apprentice yes yes I
you were in those boardrooms oh my god
they keep you know Porcher but they keep
talking about the fact that you know I
think Tom Arnold is doing a whole show
but the fact that there are tapes right
dropping n bombs in these torturous
boardrooms okay first of all I'm being
tortured right now because I just have
to say that shot of her truss is still
up so is he dropping racial see you know
what I here's what happened to me in the
boardroom this was the bucket most
hurtful but funny story and it led me to
get my weight loss surgery okay so we're
in the boardroom and it was just a given
that Trump he didn't hit on any women
that I know of but he did compliment all
the women and but I know off the bat I'm
a fat [ __ ] too in menopause he's not
gonna compliment me I'm he's gonna leave
me out of course so well I'm settled
with it he didn't seem like he liked you
though no yeah he liked me as a guy to
the end yeah I I got fired I would stop
for is off first
well yeah and you me and Penn Jillette
kind of hung in there not a cop go ahead
that's true very true I'm not spiritual
being
so anyway
here's the DA's report act so here's
what happened so we're in the boardroom
and every week he's picking on a
different woman two compliments it was
like Teresa you look beautiful today
Aubrey look more attractive with every
coming week one day Jim I don't know
where it [ __ ] I was dying he goes
Lisa and I'm like oh my god he's
recognized me as a woman it's my turn
and he goes Lisa doesn't Teresa look
beautiful I am sick of being the fat
[ __ ] all the time now I'm taking care of
this [ __ ] but yeah he did like me I
stayed on for a really long time I
earned 130 grand for the gay men's
health crisis so it was worse happy yeah
but you know what happened it didn't do
its part
yes rich Lisa's in the middle of a story
excuse I like how he's still rocking the
old-time jewels huh I know it was 61
years it's cool it's like he's found
that personas and he has perfect fingers
to have rings on them you're saying
about the boardroom yeah yeah no I never
heard him say any racial stuff I just
remember once he brought Milania and we
asked had a kiss her ring like she was
somebody and I'm just like you know who
cares but he treated you well oh yeah
well again he just I think you respected
I was hard worker that was about it have
you seen him since President or no no I
think he's scared too scared
tell align himself with something like
you know with racial content and stuff
even though he's good with all those
guys but we just filming right yeah but
the freaking um Oldman Philbin children
you know could be the guy we did when we
roasted Trump they made me at the Friars
dress up like a nun and so I wouldn't
offend him they said coming out on nuns
mouths with you on TV no no at the fryer
did that one fire it wasn't out
memorable when you did it
however I don't recall that happening
we're in the [ __ ] newspaper yeah
that's good Ohio yeah what that you yeah
we got a [ __ ] movie [ __ ] you fight
we're pretending to have a mic I guess
I've been told on my life not to so when
I hear it on radio yeah we'll try to if
you wanted this is reminisce you can
close your deal with her listen that is
not true I've been celibate for six
years how do you realize I have a
night's has not it has been both my
choice and meant six years no one has
given me an offer in six years
mutual [ __ ] ever since my divorce from
Jimmy big balls
I was like you know what I'm gonna wait
until I work on myself enough to attract
an equal because Jimmy's a great guy but
he was not an equal I don't know it's
like when you call a short guy tall
that's right nice to her you've been
very mean the whole now where are you
performing because this is very exciting
to have you in studio actually it will
be back here at Radio City fantastic
February I think we'd do Valentine's Day
oh but in the meantime you're you got a
show yeah I've got a hit properties with
Nathan Nathan Morris it's a new producer
it's on the Do It Yourself Network I
always like to the I why yeah oh yeah
okay DIY Oh
this Saturday at 10:30 at premiers which
is I like those they're all I kind of
fixer-upper shows yeah this one this is
fun man but we dug in a little bit this
was a pretty expensive for us we did I
bought a house on the Golf Course in
Orlando for about 1.7 million and put
about 1.3 in it and went on sale last
week for about $4.99 well Golf Course
it's a Lake Nona beautiful course yeah
yeah we found a house that had a double
lot it would sit for a while don't know
why why anybody didn't buy it what was
wrong with it just dated and way too
much work to do but I mean you know we
we felt that would hit being on the golf
course it would it would move if we did
it correctly and we think it will was
everything it was the whole thing
completely [ __ ] up because sometimes
if you could I looked at a place when I
was trying to buy a place on Fifth
Avenue and it was if it was too
expensive but it was amazing there was a
gigantic outdoor deck and I like there's
something wrong with this place you just
knew was right it was just completely
dated that we had to do every single I
mean it's a 80 200 square feet so we
redid all the bedrooms all the bathrooms
kitchen new roof new driveway new pavers
the garages were done over a new pool
okay claim room was it a clay roof out
that she didn't cut yeah they had
shingles but we did a concrete roof okay
now but it wasn't like this like you
like this sometimes you get a house of
that there's like [ __ ] fire ants that
had like use my house so in that bad
amazing that you see shows like that and
you watch him do it and you sit there
going like yeah he's making money doing
that I could do that I should do that
yeah you convince yourself physically oh
my god did you always have this talent
because it's a really tough job dad
always made sure we could use our hands
as kids so we always had to figure out
who's putting up the money before oh um
is a partnership with me and my manager
in another part so you guys are that's
you're taking the whole risk oh yeah the
network is not putting the network is
what about that much you know hotel
maybe or honestly I think that they
weren't expecting a project this big
projects this big they wouldn't had that
kind of budget and how long did it take
to do the renovation took on a little
over a year Wow places before though you
bought and flip place what happened was
is that I was in
a lotta lucrative property with my
manager and the other partner and then I
do a lot of construction and design
stuff for my home so this was an idea we
thought we'd bring it all together and
try to see how did you do a lot you shut
out most of it oh you know no no we we
we have it we have a team of guys that
we work with I physically work yeah so
we don't go in there oh you travel with
your own guys and they'll actually win
their own do you trust their work do you
have fights with them cuz that's why I
like love adore listed and all those
shows us cuz they always fight yeah
fight with Mike my contractor nice him
and I always we kind of differ but he
always winds up getting to the end and
seeing what I'm looking in all the years
you've done that how many times have you
had a contractor come in under the
estimate ever happened it was funny a
lot of them try to because they want to
be on TV
mmm and we had an incident like that in
this situation with somebody kind of
underbid the job and as they got halfway
through it
they quit so we had to finish it up why
am i crying today could integrity knew
they couldn't and financially so what's
to get you know just those two golf
courses at least one in Vegas where
people bought property on the course
cursor on a course and the course just
closed or stick out and the [ __ ]
property is dead so what's the gallon is
this a private course or a public or
private is looking at you like I never
what happened what happens to the golf
course it depends on what happens to it
after what happens to a golf day usually
built rebuild more houses on develop on
did you learn this business as you were
in boys to men it's like you know this
isn't gonna last forever I need a backup
or were you always into well I've always
liked to beat I was in the real estate
but years ago I don't have any money so
you can't right there's no money so as I
got no I got older I started kind of
investing a little bit and didn't got a
little bit more risky and whatnot and
then like I said I was always doing it
you know design constructs and stuff on
stuff that I had so it was more
something that I've always wanted to do
just it just happened to come together
at this time wait after boys to men you
didn't have money nor before that okay
because a lot of musicians get screwed
yeah
good we're good welcome and when you
know we're Vegas now I love you guys
know that right yeah right yeah we've
been about five years now at what place
at the Moscow so we've been to Miraj for
five years we just signed up for another
three years right it's [ __ ] great
stationary place for us because before
that we did a lot of traveling around
the world doing a bunch of toys and
stuff and it was just crazy on the body
so it's kind of good to be there 22 to
22 weekend's out of the year so you kind
of have a place in Vegas or do you stay
in the hotel I stay in Florida I fly
back and forth and I should do five we
do three Friday Saturday Sunday that's
it so wait you will fly in just for the
three days then go right home after
either go home or go to another
corporate gig or something oh so we have
to do good one but Jeanie a comic opener
they have that aces of comedy they bring
all those comedians in and sometimes
they need to go before us or after a
certain well except Tim nobody likes him
they go after you course the follow boys
tonight I would not that's tough well
you know what it is is that big like
it's not it's not the same show we go on
and they clear out the house and then
they bring yeah so it's kind of how many
seats is the theater 1300 okay nice
which is great for us cuz yeah you know
it's just enough I mean people come in
from all over the world which is great
for us because like I said normally we
had to travel to all of them so now we
know what Vegas being a Universal City
everybody comes in and [ __ ] three
nights in C for three nights that's what
Ralphie had at whatever place yet
Thursday Friday Saturday yep it's
perfect if that's a gift for a performer
were you there when the shooting
happened
we that's the only weekend we weren't
there oh you got lucky right there yes
as tourism taking a hit after that did
early on Jaime you know Vegas that's
back of strong people that name you know
this they live off of you know people
working and you know if you see nose and
stuff like that so they had to jump back
in Vegas Vegas for three days is great
in and out when you're awake oh you want
to kill yourself you feel so dirty yeah
and I hate guys in Vegas they think they
could do anything and you're drunk in
the elevator grab I [ __ ] hate well
and also everyone's having fun except
you because you're working you have to
be fresh for the show and stuff like
that so I was felt it was a big party I
wasn't invited to which leads eat and
drink and do all that again
on Friday and out on the read on all
right
so you go home after you get 22 euro
he's in school right great
you don't just spend a few F do you stay
in the hotel or do you go somewhere else
yeah we have Suites in the hotel we get
the same one every every time we come in
so that's nice yes sweet new Vegas hotel
it doesn't suck no no you boys a dump
travel questions you fly in day of show
I hate flying day of show why I'd rather
fly
no I'm so packed a flight will be late
you'll miss the money that's what I
worry about they do is we always what do
you say that we always I'm always on the
first thing out there's always two
options oh yes the first its flights the
first ones never delayed it builds right
can be if the flight crews I declared
illegal cuz they came in late tonight
before that weather yeah like I said we
had backups and most of the time to do
it the first flight is a direct flight
but unfortunately in my case nothing
flies to rekt out of Tampa so Tampa well
that's the epitaph layout of right brain
like the house we did is in Orlando and
I'm two hours south when's the last time
one of you missed a gig because there's
three guys coming in we don't that's
amazing to rely on other guys yeah we've
never no not because of that we might
have good gig my take cancels or
something but no just me going to a gig
I panic I would hate to ever lie on two
other guys exactly yeah what do you
suppose it is about you guys that you're
smart enough to keep this thing going
like you know mostly you haven't
self-destructed you know the three of
you at least have maintained together
like you're still doing regular game
thing is just how we were we were
brought into the business and and and we
we did what a lot of kids don't do what
we listened listened to what people told
us to do you know the the greats the
temptations and Stevie Wonder people
like that taught us how to be around for
a long time so we took all that
knowledge in and yeah we fight we dope
this stuff like everybody else but
overall I mean we know that nothing's
ever gonna be stronger than a hole and
this is just what we've been put here to
do so everything else that we do is
extra what's the long as you guys really
not talking maybe a couple weeks oh okay
sorry brief talk all right temptations
I gave it Ruffins or Dennis Edwards
that's tough man
as a musician and an entertainer they
all have jobs
my favorite band I think I think that
they brought different things each one
of them so I mean it's one of those
things
you can plug one out and plug one in but
they both can't do the same thing I met
I met David Ruffin store in Detroit and
I was starstruck because it what is it
with you and celebrities kids I'm sorry
about today
aces are my favorite [ __ ] band really
of all time when they used to do TCB
with The Supremes on TV you should see
taking care of business [ __ ] amazing
no one's better than the temperature
there's no more Sabbath is better than
the competing species over Earth Wind &
Fire
me personally I hate you I mean again
I'm a vocal guy someone gotta lean
towards vocal group than a band that's
men yeah and all other stuff I'm old
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sixties music or Motown well
we've had and all of our stuff after
them which is why we were able to I
think sustain because our parents tell
us that music when we were kids we
didn't grow up with that music either
but you know it's the type of music that
can last for a long time and by the
grace of God people have passed our
music going to their kids so 27 years
later was still able to do it did you
guys try any of that poppy stuff like
when boy bands because your sound was
pretty different from boy bands that
actually came out before the boy bands
right came after us so it was like we
were already set with the sound that we
had and we we were on Motown that was
our label in the original days when we
started on Motown so we learned from all
those guys to do what's right because
it's funny when you listen to like a boy
band song like you listen going like
this is clearly dated like it's kind of
it's hokey it's kind of but like boys to
men songs they just said they're just
R&B source weren't those bands casted a
lot of those boy bands yeah yeah no
there's no cancer that's not a word
Casas no test is the if I stutter it's
casted he was big boned it all right
because I used to be a hundred pounds
heavier and all I used to like that the
brothers would always find something
good about it they'd say oh yeah like in
light skin did yeah
anyone said he was right ever today yeah
yeah bosses bosses right walking that
tightrope of comfortability where he
falls over to racism very very soon yes
sure what is insulting you in 1840
properties Nathan Morris it's the new
series 8 premiere yeah yeah DIY
Network's this Saturday at 10:30 p.m. I
would actually love to see that because
a [ __ ] a million dollars into a
property have a lot of money then it
probably also keeps you sane
contribution did nothing keeps you sane
doing in the band knowing you've got
this stuff going on outside like you've
got your individual thing so over the
weekend you do the thing you get out of
there and you do your own stuff yeah it
kind of parallels to me because you know
the construction design stuff for me is
just as creative as writing songs or
producing the performance oh it's just
another way to create so what I knew
whatever I was gonna do action would be
something creative so it kind of kind of
works for me do you kind of go like you
get in a fight with the other guys right
and you're going on a plane you you [ __ ]
you I got a show [ __ ] yourself it's
going dude light-skinned [ __ ]
that's my thing I would do that
sometimes show it like that you know I
mean you say it in your head but you
know I can and you're nice so there's
never gonna be any video you say having
a meltdown on TMZ no no no it's
fantastic I love it at least is just
looking for the fight you're just met
and dealt with like Smokey Robinson and
[ __ ] have you met Diana Ross yes oh
he's all of them Diana Gordy Stevie
Michael his Gordy still alive yeah how
old is he that I don't know
Hades I'm such a driving range next
standing Nexus which one of his
relatives smokey that's one of the
greatest songwriters in Motown history
actually
what do you say to you fanboy out we
were talking about that do you yeah do
you uh do you do that when you meet
somebody or do you just kind of try to
play it cool like a were just two equals
actually yeah is it for me is because we
were exposed to it so early as kids
would be an mo town it yeah the mic went
out you can you jostle that cable oh now
he's gone I know that's ridicu thing
yeah you're finite studio please the
host we just didn't like the way I
didn't like the way look at his little
turtle feet hands together you see what
you see a man wearing a jewelry like
let's say a man's wearing big gold rings
to try to announce to the world that
he's doing financially he's doing very
well do you think it's important that he
doesn't have short stubby fingers
attention to should he be highlighting
those it's like Oscar Pistorius wearing
gold shoes to my head to draw oh but
seriously you should not be wearing
rings on finger with your fingers like
that it's not right he knows he doesn't
want to say it you don't think he's
terrible would you have stubby weird
feeling a normal hand yeah you're like a
normal human man's hand yeah but he's
not not a normal I look it's a little
sad yeah but he is passing a claymation
you can't tell
well you can't tell if you're getting
lapped either by the silence
you can't tell the his finger you're
still here you can't tell his fingers
don't meet on the other side
[Laughter]